in a recent interview with filmmaker
david o russell i believe he admitted
that the most difficult place for him as
a director was sort of being in this
position where he didn't know what film
he was going to make next the sort of
unknown territory have you ever found
yourself in this position and so what
did you do yeah i have i have found
myself not knowing what i should do next
I was never one of these guys I was
everybody's filmmakers and always end me
these guys that had like this I've got a
stack of screenplays behind I got I got
stories for the rest of my life that I
want to make they're all ready to go
like I never I was never prolific that
way as a writer and inevitably I did
facing it right now really the movies
that I ended up making them were more
personal to me you know like the handful
of movies like the big empty or
Cucaracha or some guy who kills people
one of my last movies whenever I
finished those movies it was never like
I had this thing necessarily on deck
that I was burning to make in other
words it when it was done it was almost
like the one next or okay you know I
mean I have things I want to do but it's
it's interesting I think when you make a
movie that's important it's filling the
space or this hole in your life or this
or this need to figure something out so
you're dealing with it through this
particular project and then it's not
like okay now I just have this other big
thing I need to deal with all move out
of it it doesn't seem to work that way
for me so I right now I know I want to
make a movie Ryan and I Ryan Ryan and I
want to make another movie and we've
been talking about ideas since we wrap
some guy who kills people and they're
definitely some that are more propulsive
and more interesting than others but
it's not like we've like we knew like
okay we're going to do this and then
we're going to do this it was like I
think part of it has to be about finding
the thing that's necessary to make in a
way I think the best pieces of work or
art come out of something that is like
personally necessary something you need
to like deal with or figure like I said
sort of explore it's not even about like
I want to make a move
about racism or anything about it's
about like this is what's going on in my
life this is what's bothering me can I
find a story that somehow articulates
that that's not an easy thing to do if
you are a journeyman director it's you
can just go do on to the next script
whatever it is and I made a movie after
some guy who kills people that was
totally like well we made that mega
shark movie and you could do something
like that and we like you and we know
you can handle it you want to do this
thing and it's like here's a paycheck
and I'm like yeah I like this kind of
thing I'll do it but it's big it's a
different thing from coming up with that
thing that you need to make you know I
have higher hopes for films that I have
to make than ones that I'm hired to make
because I feel that those are the best
where I can do my best stuff so I
totally understand that void excuse me
or limbo that can occur after you make a
movie I mean look at Kubrick not that I
believe in the last thing I'm doing is
comparing myself to him but I'm saying
is that there's probably a reason why he
made so few movies is because he was
carefully weighing what his next thing
was going to be like why am I making
this thing skipper could have made
triple the amount of movies he made he
certainly would have gotten the funding
but he was look at this is a guy who
could make anything most of us are like
okay well if you know like someone said
to me now okay well all that like
trying to search and find which one I've
got a bucket of money here that you can
make a movie but you got to make it next
month I'd be like okay I'll suddenly on
the inspiration I know exactly what I'm
going to be so a Kubrick was in a
position where he could have made any
movie he will want to almost at any
point I mean after he made Spartacus or
2001 he could make anything you want
people are like clamoring and he spent
years between projects because for
whatever reason his process was I've got
to find the perfect thing to do I think
that's that may be part of the neurosis
of the creative person is trying to
figure out what you're going to paint
next unless you're just breathing i wish
i was just brimming with
no ideas but you know so I think it's a
different type of personality
you